Hi everyone, in this lesson, we're gonna continue
to make a layered material system,
using the old way using material functions.
So let's get started.
Now that we have our moss materials set up,
we're gonna make sure that everything's
in the right order and the way that you need it.
And you can see you should have exactly what I have
for this particular material.
So let's move on and we need to look at
our wood material function.
So let's double click on that and open that up.
It's off screen, so let me pull that in screen here.
There we go.
And in here, we have to do the same thing.
Let's go and stop the preview.
And we're going to make a material attributes.
So make material attributes.
And we're gonna go ahead and pull that string
into here for now.
So what we wanna do is build out something
a little bit more complex when it comes
to the normal input.
So we can have control visually of how things should look.
And then if you want, you can add what you need
for the wood control for your object
if you need for your scene.
So let's go ahead and actually make a input for our tint.
So let's go and create a function input.
There we go, let's go pull that up.
In this function input, we wanna make sure
that we're set to vector three.
And you'll see by default that is set in
and we are good to go.
I like to turn on the preview when I can,
you don't necessarily need that in this version of Unreal.
And older versions you needed it so that it showed up
to the party so you can see what you add.
I'm gonna keep my finger to the L key
and left click and do lerp.
I'm gonna pull that input function here.
Let's actually give it a name.
I just forgot we forgot to name it.
So we're gonna call this wood tint.
There we go, perfect.
Wood tint's in there.
Let's go ahead and add some controls here
for darkening in this particular case.
So we wanna go ahead and keep my finger
to the one key left click.
And we'll pull that right into the B channel there.
And we'll just set that to a one.
And this could be something we can fix later
if we want to.
But for now we'll just keep this here as a placeholder.
And we wanna go ahead and bring in an alpha
and that alpha is going to be the texture.
So let's go ahead and put that texture in there.
So let's go ahead and keep the T key left click
and let's go ahead and call up that bark.
And it's an oak bark.
So we'll go ahead and type in T underscore oak, oak bark.
There we go, albedo.
And we're gonna go ahead and plug that
right into the alpha there.
There we go.
And then now we're gonna bring this across
to the base color.
Fantastic.
So let's go and move this up just a bit.
A little bit more organized, a little bit more room.
And then now we're gonna head
and do some editing for the rough.
And we'll put in some defaults just for the spread
control of how that rough's going to look.
So let's go and hit the T key again.
We're gonna go ahead and grab in the details
that same texture set.
So oak, there we go.
Roughness, pull that up.
Don't need to expose any parameters.
I do get into that habit, but material functions
play by different rules.
So I don't have to worry about that as much.
I'm gonna keep my finger on the one key
and we'll set this first prime to 0.5.
This is gonna be at the top of alert.
Keep your finger on the L key.
And we'll drag that 0.5 into the A channel there
as a nice placeholder for the mix that we're doing.
And we wanna make sure the effect kind of turns on.
So keep our finger on the one key again.
And then in this constant, we'll set that to one
in the details and pull that into the B channel.
And finally, we're gonna grab this texture
just like we did above and pull this into the A,
but we're not gonna grab the RGB.
We're gonna grab, we need the black and white
information that's pretty solid and strong
in the red channel.
And we'll pull that into the alpha there.
Pretty cool, awesome so far.
Now we wanna go ahead and pull this
right into the roughness.
Right there, there we go, awesome.
So finally, we wanna control a little bit
of the normals here.
So things look a little bit believable
and just give you some options here.
And we're gonna kind of follow the same playbook,
but not, we're actually going to get the RGB
and split them up using multiplies and a pens,
which you've learned in other classes,
we can use a pen vector to be able to split information
and control it.
That's pretty much what we're gonna do here.
So I'm gonna keep my finger the T key.
This is gonna be my texture.
And then in this texture, we're gonna pull up
the same set of textures here to get the normal
T underscore Oak, there we go, get that normal.
And we're gonna go ahead and hit the M key
for a multiply, M key for another multiply.
And we're gonna need a function input
to control this one.
Now we don't have a function input for the roughness,
but if you wanted to, you could add it
kind of the same what we did here for the albedo.
We just have some defaults.
So, but here we need to have it here
like we do have it for our albedo.
So we're gonna actually pull that in.
So let's go ahead and pull up a function input.
Here we go.
And we're gonna set that to a scaler
because we wanna control a range
and let's give it a name.
So we're gonna call this the normal,
gotta be able to spell that, multiplier.
I think that's what I called it before.
Yep, there we go.
And let's go ahead and the default should be fine.
I always turn the preview just to force a habit
and we're going to plug these in appropriately.
So I'm gonna grab the first little string here
and pull it into the B channel and multiply.
I'm gonna grab the green channel
in here into this multiply
because now we're controlling the green when we do so.
I'm gonna grab the red channel
and pull it into the B of this multiply
and grab this input to also make sure it magnifies
or changes the strength of this multiply here
which would be the red.
So we're controlling the green and the red by doing this.
And then we're gonna create an append vector.
Let's grab those append vectors.
There we go.
Pull that in.
It'll just say append.
That's fine.
Remember, Unreal will tell you what you're looking at.
If you do control, control alt.
So just keep that in mind.
If you're not sure what you have, if it's the right one
because there are a few names
that kind of cross pollinate a little bit.
All right.
So we're gonna go ahead and pull that multiply
into the eight channel that append.
I'm gonna grab this multiply
and put into the B channel with your pet.
And I'm just gonna duplicate it by doing control D
used to be control W, but now control D
and I'm gonna grab the blue channels
so I can control the blue color information
and grab that append and pull it.
This append here into that second appends A channel there.
And then finally, we're gonna pull that
right into the normal.
There we go.
I'm gonna just pull this back a little bit
so it makes more sense.
Awesome.
So now we've built out our wood material function.
And if you need to go and give it a preview
to see how it's looking and it's looking pretty good.
All right.
In the next video, we're gonna go ahead
and start bringing these all together.
And you're gonna see a layered effect, which we created.
Thanks again.